I haven't done a personally focused
video for some time and it's a little
bit overdue I think and something that a
student asked me about provides me with
a good occasion for this I would say
that it's now becoming a pattern about
once a year I have a student who comes
to me with some sort of problem or a
question and would like some advice
about it something personal and I see
sort of a larger larger picture and then
I shoot a video on it last year it was a
student who had a friend who was very
troubled by his adoption and the
circumstances surrounding it and I shot
a video about being adopted and this
video here I mean you can see the title
it's about love and infatuation and I
had a student who wrote on his final
exam sort of addendum to it and he said
I've got a question about love and
infatuation that's been bothering me and
I'll read the whole question in a moment
what I'm going to do in this video is
address the issues the questions the
topics that he's got wove into this this
paragraph because they're very
interesting talk a little bit about my
own experience and hopefully stay fairly
on point and I'll also talk a little bit
about some of the bigger picture issues
with with love and infatuation and maybe
even give a little bit of advice I don't
have a ton of advice state though but I
think there's some things I can say so
before I do that I want to give you a
little bit of framing of you know how
this came up so this semester this is
the final exam for the intro philosophy
class that I taught this semester and
the intro class I switch it up every
every semester give it a different theme
this this this time around I picked the
theme love friendship and desire so we
read Plato's symposium and we read
Cicero's on friendship and we've read
Aristotle's Nicomachean ethics book
eight and nine we read some Thomas
Aquinas if I read some Descartes and you
know we read the love letters between
Abelard and Eloise
and so it was a very fruitful class I
don't know that they actually learned
quite as much about metaphysics
epistemology as they ought to but they
learned a lot about ethics and about
human nature and about how the emotions
work and I think this is very useful to
do there's a lot of wisdom contained in
these these discussions and speculations
about love and friendship and desire and
infatuation and relationships and how we
ought to treat each other and how to
structure our lives in ancient and
medieval and early modern thought that's
why I teach this stuff so this is a this
is a young man who has been thinking
about these things quite a bit he can he
made some really great contributions in
class and in writing so I know that he's
been thinking about these things my wife
pointed something out as well and this
is also kind of the framing thing that
it's it's in certain ways kind of a sign
of respect he had a student ask you
about these these sort of issues and at
first I was like well really you know
and she's like yeah I mean that means
that they actually first off they think
that you might know something about this
that they don't know and that by itself
you know is a big step because the
adolescents and young adults usually
think that that they know a hell of a
lot more than they do that's how they
get into trouble and they tend to be and
I know this from my own experience of
having been one they tend to be a bit
dismissive of what subtle adults have to
say they think that every generation
seems to think that it's facing unique
new struggles that you know love is
somehow different for it than it is for
those old people there and back in their
day you know everything was so much so
much simpler and if you read literature
and you read history you find out that
was never the case log was always
complicated we have sort of images of a
past where that was the case and some
people were may be able to live lives
where that seemed to be the case but
that wasn't a universal thing across the
board so it's you know it's actually a
sign of wisdom to ask
older people who you think are someone
on the ball to give you some some
guidance or advice or some insight about
these sort of things and I think she's
right you know
I'm not sure what it is in my manner
that that makes me seem personable or
receptive but apparently this student
thought that I was somebody who he's
willing to trust with some you know some
fairly not detailed but some fairly
personal revelations so let me read what
he actually has to say there's there's
this pretty pretty interesting stuff so
he says I've recently been in contact
with a girl I used to be infatuated with
when I was a teen I no longer feel
infatuated with girls however because I
haven't been in contact I feel as though
the infatuation feelings have come back
so this is a guy who actually has it
quite together who isn't just sort of
like flitting from from girl to girl to
girl from from object of affection to
the next one to the next one he's
looking for something bigger and better
but there's this this girl from his past
that he's now you know feeling these
emotions towards again so he goes on
infatuation is scary because you see the
other person through rose-colored
glasses even though that person isn't
perfect my question is what is the best
way to deal with infatuation because it
isn't love it always seems to not work
out and
also can infatuation have return to love
so this is actually great stuff I mean
this is this is the sort of perennial
matters that that younger people and
even older people in every generation
throughout time have to deal with we
haven't always called it infatuation in
earlier times they called this you know
eros or desire or libido or akan coupe
ascents or you know there's all sorts of
names for it but it's the same it's the
same basic thing and infatuation is it's
within the spectrum of love
well oftentimes we associate infatuation
with just sexual desire but it's not
it's not just or even primarily about
sex it's about it's about a sort of
romantic attitude towards towards the
other towards seeing them like he says
with rose-colored glasses seeing
everything that's really good about them
perhaps projecting some of that there or
you know reading things in that aren't
there and feeling this sense of
attraction of wanting to be in their
presence of wanting to think about them
even if not being able to not think
about them and to a certain extent even
feeling a sense of awe or or wonder or
curiosity in their presence and it makes
us very vulnerable to the other person
as well we care about what they think
how they you know perceive our
appearance whether they smile at us
whether they frown whether they give us
the time of day or don't all these
things can take on great significance
and so I think he's really you know he's
really smart for for saying hey
infatuation can be a lot of trouble so
he's really saying three different
things about infatuation here and I
think we should look at each one of
these in turn he says infatuation leads
us to look at the other person through
rose-colored glasses even though that
person isn't perfect
he wants to know what's the best way to
deal with infatuation because it's not
love and he says it always seems to not
work out so we got three different
interesting issues there and then to two
questions so let's look at these issues
in turn does infatuation make us look at
the other person with the proverbial
rose-colored glasses yeah it tends to
make us overlook their their flaws you
know if you think about this is just an
example what happened when we went to
HDTV and how people were complaining
that the newscasters now you can see
like all the pores of their skin
now they're wrinkled
hgtv was giving us a more accurate
representation of how people really look
and people were looking at and they're
like I don't think I want to watch that
you know it's kind of creeping me out
and infatuation think of infatuation as
being like the ultimate foundation
makeup it covers covers over all the
blemishes and all that all the cracks
and crevices and that's what it does it
surrounds a person with kind of an aura
now that that that's kind of good in
some ways because nobody is perfect and
let's just think about physical
appearance you you can pick the most
attractive person who you know you think
is attractive and then change the light
and they're not gonna be quite as
attractive you're gonna find some some
flaw to them or you know there's things
over time where you're like man I love
that quality about that person and then
after a while you're like they're
driving me nuts because of that I
thought that was really great this is
one of those things that happens when
opposites attract right you're like oh
man I love that person because she's so
outgoing and I'm kind of shy then after
you're well after a while and you're
like man she's always dragging me into
stuff that I don't want to be involved
with so you know it's it's kind of good
to have some things paved over and to
look at them optimistically through the
rose-colored glasses but there's danger
signs that you also want to watch out
for as well you know somebody is prone
to cheating on you or to stealing your
stuff or to playing fast and loose with
your privacy or you know you can think
of all sorts insanely jealous
infatuation can blind you to those and
that's not good and that infatuation can
play into this whole dynamic where they
screw you over or they do something
that's you know stupid or thoughtless
and you know you you're bothered by it
but they said well you know I really
like them and and you feel a little bit
ashamed of being taken advantage of and
then you you know you look at it more
optimistically and then you're just
setting yourself up to get get treat
badly again so yeah infatuation can be
dangerous in that respect and can lead
us to to have bad judgment about the
people who were involved with if it's
just a matter of having coffee with the
person and hanging out with them
probably not that big a deal if it's you
know hooking up with them and then
moving in with them that could actually
be life you know life-changing
consequences depending on you know what
they're like and yeah it's good to bear
this in mind you know you're when you
get involved with somebody you're not
just vulnerable to them physically
you're vulnerable to them emotionally in
terms of your goals and plans in terms
of your finances in terms of your circle
of friends so there's there's all sorts
of other goods that that come up over
for that so that's the rose-colored
glasses issue
let's now let's think about infatuation
in law is infatuation fundamentally
different from love it really depends on
what you mean by love and infatuation is
a narrower term like I said we have a
lot of other terms that we can translate
as infatuation but love is a very broad
term and love can mean a lot of
different things if you want to see some
examples of this watch those videos from
my intro class and see how many
different models of love we talked about
where friendship is a kind of love and
friendship can be of all different sorts
you know it can be about the person
themselves and this intimate connection
it could be about pleasure it could be
about usefulness we have the kind of
love that that parents and children have
for each other you know the country can
be an object of love the divine can be
an object of love animals can be an
object of love there's all sorts of
modalities to love so you you know when
you say I want to be careful about
infatuation because it isn't love I
think what's really being said there is
something more like this I need to be
careful about infatuation because in
fact
raishin can crowd out or cut off the
possibility of or even you know
masquerade as these other kinds of love
that are in the long run perhaps more
valuable but you don't want to like you
know totally leave infatuation out you
know if you think about a marriage for
example a marriage shouldn't just be
this sort of self giving love that that
Christians call agape and it shouldn't
just be a friendship it should include
the erotic dimension desire for each
other of attraction to each other as
well that's what makes it complete but
you wouldn't just you know this is where
a lot of people go wrong they they hook
up and they're like yeah let's make a
marriage out of this that's not going to
be enough because there's this other
stuff over here and the question is how
much are these going to interfere with
each other that's a judgment question
that you can't settle across the board
for every single relationship you have
to look at the relationship you have to
look at the person and this goes to that
question can infatuation turn into law
can't infatuation lead to these other
kinds of love like say a deep abiding
friendship yes it can but that doesn't
mean that it automatically will so
that's that's the second thing now let's
think about the the third one
infatuation always seems to not work out
well why is that the case a couple
different explanations we can give for
that one would be that infatuation by
its very nature is kind of ephemeral
kind of short-lived if it's really about
you know you think about this but it's
really about sexual desire once you have
sex then you know you're satisfied and
that's it
you might want have sex some more but
you know and you might be sort of
happier now that you've actually had it
but you know that that's about as high
as it goes and you know Plato has has
some of those characters talk about that
in their the symposium
as the bad kind of love and the same
thing could go for for other things as
well it's not always like I said it's
not always about sex sometimes we just
want to have that person around us and
with us and oftentimes we're very
confused about what it is that we really
want from the other person who were
attracted to who were infatuated with
but so why doesn't it work out sometimes
it's just because it's short-lived and
we get infatuated with somebody and like
I said you know traits that we find
endearing at the start after the
infatuation starts to fade we'll like I
can't stand this person and they're
they're BS anymore I gotta get the hell
out of here so you know there's that and
I think that infatuation if we give too
much sway to it and here I'm actually
talking from from experience can crowd
out those other perhaps more valuable
types of affection or love you know like
friendship like charity or agape like
like the you know sort of thing that
develops just with companionship they
can become too much so to speak and if
you don't have these other things the
relationship is probably not going to be
all that all that viable over time all
that long lived now if you have these
other things the infatuation could in
fact develop into other types of love
you know you could start dating this
person and you become friends with them
and now you go through some common
experiences together you're there with
them when when their grandpa dies and
you know you see them graduate and walk
across the stage and you know you tell
them your hopes and dreams and they tell
you their hopes and dreams and you you
become close you become connected with
each other you get to meet their family
they meet your family and you know
people get along or don't get along
these are the sort of things that that
relationships are really composed of and
that's possible
with the starting point of infatuation
it really did
hands-on what kind of person that we're
talking about and there's there's no
information here that would lead me to
be able to give more detailed advice
that's something that each person would
have to figure out for themselves this
young man in his own case but I mean
there's there's certain things that like
I said are sort of red flags and if
infatuation isn't blinding you to them
then that that can help so do I have any
any useful advice here's what I would
say it's really great that this young
man actually recognizes the difference
between infatuation and other things
that we call love and that it you know
it doesn't it doesn't substitute for
them and that it can be dangerous and
you know preclude them or occlude them
or however you want to put it get in get
in the way of them that's a really good
good thing to have in your belt I think
it's also good that he recognizes just
how strong infatuation can be this is
the problem what we call a moral
philosophy the problem of across the
upper self-control oftentimes we we know
what the good is and we know what the
bad is and we know what we ought to be
doing but we find ourselves kind of
pulled over here and we could resist
that if we really really really wanted
to if we persevered in our our choices
but that's really tough to do and then
we find ourselves you know sort of
getting getting drawn into things that
work even at the time we're like man I
shouldn't be doing this but but do you
do it and so that's something else to
pay attention to another thing that I
would say is if you do choose to get
involved with this person do not cut off
your friends and family and use them as
a sounding board if you have decent
friends and your friends don't like the
person who you're going out with there's
probably something that they're attuned
to that you're missing out on because
you're wearing those rose colored
glasses or you're wearing blinders right
like a horse
in drawing a carriage well oftentimes
people who are bad for you will actually
want to sideline your friends and family
and isolate you from them you when
you're involved with another person you
want them to actually be in sort of a
harmonious relationship with the rest of
your people who matter to you the people
that you love the people that you care
about and who care about you and so you
want to you want to use them as sounding
boards you want to take advice from you
know parents or in this case you know
from a college professor who you think
actually knows something or you know
your friends oftentimes oftentimes your
friends won't be able to put their
finger exactly on what's off with
somebody but they'll say yeah that I
don't know about this seems like there's
something off you know the jealousy is
kind of weird there's there's a strange
vibe from this person provided that your
friends are actually decent people they
think they can be very good sounding for
so that's another piece of advice that I
would give and I would just you know I
would keep on thinking about these
issues it couldn't hurt to actually
write down some of this stuff this is a
last bit of advice that'll get you
I would actually sort of like keep track
over time about of your feelings and
about what you're tempted to do and how
you're how you're feeling about your
feelings and what you actually do decide
to do because that way if things get
dicey or seem off you've got a kind of
paper trail that you could look back at
and say oh wait a second I thought
something was kind of weird back here
because a lot of times our memories get
kind of jumbled up and you know when our
emotions get involved if we've got it
down on paper I think sometimes that can
be very helpful you don't even have to
put it on paper you could you know
create a Google Doc that only you have
access to don't make it public
and and you know chart it out there that
would that wouldn't be a bad idea also
don't share it with the person if it's
about that so I
really enjoyed thinking about this and I
hope here I'm just sort of addressing my
former students but this can go for my
other YouTube viewers it is of any help
to you I hope that this actually gives
you some insight some some framework for
thinking about these things I hope that
if you are going to have a relationship
with this person that you've you've
you're now well equipped to sort of see
it through and think about the things
that you need to take account of at the
right time so that you'll actually be
happy because a good relationship I
think and a lot of the philosophers who
we studied in this class think this as
well is really integral to the good life
so that's about all the advice that I
have